the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon and a song of ice and fire
update video all right folks in this new
video we will look at another update
from our old friend george rr martin
over on his not a blog website
now in this new video george rr martin
sets the record straight in regards to
his last not a blog update he also
mentioned something at the very end that
did get me very excited let's go over to
his website now so i can show you what
was said
he said too much to do too much to do
things are hopping as my frogs told you
down below now i could be writing long
updates here about a dozen things but i
am sure most of you would sooner i were
writing fiction films and television
shows as well as editing anthologies but
let me say a few words about matters
various and sundry we have a new book
coming out in october the rise of the
dragon an illustrated history of the
targaryen dynasty from aegon the
conqueror to the regency of the boy king
aegon the third of his name i could show
you the covers british and american but
my mighty minions have already done that
down below in his last update all you
gotta do is scroll down and enjoy the
official announcements lays out the
basic facts about the book as well so i
won't go over that again here i just
want to clear up some areas of confusion
in my blog update from march 9th scroll
down further i made mention of a lavish
coffee table book that is coming out
later this year an illustrated condensed
version of fire and blood done with ilio
garcia and linda who also helped him
with the world of ice and fire yes i was
speaking of rise of the dragon the same
book
there has been some mention of rise
being an encyclopedia but i do not think
that is accurate not unless the
definition of encyclopedia has brought
in considerably it's a history covering
the same years in events as fire and
blood but not written in world by
archmaester gildane and much condensed
from gildane's original text my friends
ilio garcia and linda of world of ice
and fire fame handled the abridgement
alright now let me stop right here for a
second so i can say something about what
he just said because i think this does
have some significance there are a lot
of fans who have been worried that
george rr martin is now too busy to be
writing the wins of winner because he's
now working on all these other things i
for one was someone who was also worried
about that if you saw his last not a
blog update he mentions how he did not
get that much writing done on the wins
of winner last year while also
mentioning how he has all of these other
novels releasing either later this year
or sometime next year well i think this
new update is to show that he's not
actually working on those other books as
much as we might think like he said
right here ilio and linda are the ones
who are handling the abridgement not
only that but one of the main reasons
they are releasing this is because of
all the new artwork that is included
which as we all know george rr martin
has nothing to do with creating that
artwork so although he does have a new
history book releasing later this year
it doesn't sound like he had to spend
too much of his own time actually
working on it himself now let's see what
else he said
we needed a shorter book to make room
for all the artwork that's the thing
about rise of the dragon it's not an
encyclopedia it's an art book and a
gorgeous one i think rise of the dragon
will include 180 brand new illustrations
from some of the finest fantasy artists
in the world
many will be in gorgeous living and
dying colors
dragons knights battles lords and ladies
castles and all the good stuff
so if you're a fan of fantasy art you
might want to pre-order your copy now so
as you can see it doesn't sound like he
did that much work on it himself at all
the other book that is mentioned in the
update on march 9th the who's who of
westeros is coming as well but not this
fall that one is way off might be a year
or two lot of work to be done it's hard
to do a who's who when i keep inventing
characters
there will be a second book coming out
this year to tie in with the debut of
house of the dragon but it won't be a
new book either just an old one with a
new cover that's fire and blood of
course the original unabridged version
by archmaester godain with new cover art
from the hbo series when i have seen the
new cover i will be sure to share it
here with you
so once again he is releasing another
book but it's not one that he actually
had to work on himself none of this
really sounds like it's taken away any
of his time from writing the wins of
winner well maybe not as much as we
think
he also says many of you reading this
are fantasy fans i know
waiting for the wins of winner i know i
know
but looking forward to the new
television shows as well the new lord of
the rings will be out september 2nd and
house of the dragon on well you will
know soon it's only march though
now what should you watch in the
meanwhile i recommend the last kingdom
based on bernard cornwell's saxton tales
the new season just went up and my wife
and i gulped it down in a few days
no it is not fantasy there is a notable
lack of dragons and magic but there are
lots of battles and betrayals and sword
fights and all that stuff ian utrid is a
warrior who could give the best of
westeros and middle earth a fight a good
show and we will miss it but we have a
feature film to look forward to at least
and cornwell has a new sharp book out
too there's more but i have other stuff
to do so i will sign off for now the
horns are blowing the frogs are hopping
alright now maybe i'm getting all
excited for nothing but did any of you
notice what he said right there at the
very end
let me read it again he said there's
more but i have other stuff to do so i
will sign off for now the horns are
blowing now i don't know about all of
you but that sounds like he is referring
to the horns blowing at the wall and
dare i say they might be blowing because
the white walkers are finally riding
down on the winds of winter to
extinguish life as we know it i don't
know why but that line got me very
excited thinking george might be in the
middle of writing those scenes when the
white walkers are finally at the wall
fighting some of our beloved characters
now i know i know it seems like we will
never see the winds of winter but i
still want to hold out hope against all
odds like i said i don't think he is
working on all of these other projects
as much as we think it honestly just
sounds like he's having elio and linda
remix his old material that way they can
release some new novels that has new
artwork i doubt he is doing much of any
writing on those novels but maybe i'm
just being too optimistic i guess we
shall see anyways let me know what all
of you think down below i am interested
in hearing your thoughts
as always i want to thank everyone for
stopping by and watching my video i hope
all of you have a great day i will see
you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you